(man) TONIGHT, JEFF FOXWORTHY
JOINS THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE HOPEFUL ENTREPRENEURS
COME SEEKING AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS,
FIVE POWERFUL, SELF‐MADE
INVESTORS WORTH BILLIONS.
IN THE TANK, THE SHARKS
ARE READY TO INVEST
USING THEIR OWN MONEY...
BUT ONLY FOR THE RIGHT PERSON
WITH THE RIGHT BUSINESS.
T‐SHIRTS, HATS, AND TANK TOPS
ARE ONLY THE BEGINNING.
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU
TO VINNY PASTORE,
STAR OF "SOPRANOS."
YOU KNOW YOU'RE A REDNECK
WHEN YOUR KIDS ARE STRAPPED
TO YOUR LUGGAGE.
(laughs)
AND IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GOOD IDEA,
THEY'LL FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A PIECE OF IT.
I THINK THAT HE'S GIVING YOU
A SUCKER DEAL.
HE MAKES NOISE. TYPICAL.
NOBODY WANTS
TO DO BUSINESS WITH YOU.
MY DEALS ARE GOOD.
(laughs)
BUT FIRST THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST CONVINCE A SHARK
TO INVEST THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO
GIVE UP OUR WHOLE DREAM.
YOU'RE NOT SELLING THAT MUCH.
WORSE THING I'VE HEARD
ON THIS SHOW.
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
KEVIN O'LEARY
KNOWS HOW TO MAKE MONEY.
HE STARTED A SOFTWARE BUSINESS
IN HIS BASEMENT,
WHICH HE EVENTUALLY SOLD
FOR $3.2 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN‐‐
THIS FIERY REAL ESTATE MOGUL
TURNED A $1,000 LOAN
INTO A REAL ESTATE EMPIRE
WORTH HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
IN THE SHARK‐FILLED CITY
OF MANHATTAN.
DAYMOND JOHN
TURNED RAGS TO RICHES
WITH HIS CLOTHING BRAND FUBU,
WHICH HAS GROSSED
OVER $6 BILLION
IN WORLDWIDE RETAIL SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC,
THE SON OF A FACTORY WORKER
TURNED TECHNOLOGY MOGUL,
SOLD HIS FIRST
INTERNET COMPANIES
FOR OVER $350 MILLION.
AND JEFF FOXWORTHY,
THE BEST‐SELLING COMEDY
RECORDING ARTIST OF ALL TIME,
USED HIS BUSINESS SAVVY
TO BRAND HIS STAND‐UP ROUTINE
INTO A MULTIMILLION‐DOLLAR
MERCHANDISING EMPIRE.
FIRST INTO THE SHARK TANK
ARE DARRYL AND RANDY LENZ
WITH A PRODUCT
TO HELP EASE THE STRESS
OF TRAVELING WITH CHILDREN.
COME ON, HONEY.
♪♪♪
(Darryl) COME ON.
COME ON, HONEY.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS DARRYL.
THIS IS MY HUSBAND RANDY.
WE'RE FROM ATLANTA, GEORGIA.
AND OUR BUSINESS
IS RIDE ON CARRY ON.
WE'RE ASKING FOR $50,000
FOR A 25% EQUITY
IN OUR BUSINESS.
NOW DOES THIS LOOK LIKE
THE WAY TO TRAVEL?
ANYONE WHO'S TRAVELED TODAY
HAS SEEN THIS SCENARIO PLAY OUT
IN AIRPORTS ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY EVERY DAY.
NOW I'VE BEEN A FLIGHT ATTENDANT
FOR 27 YEARS.
I'VE WATCHED COUNTLESS FAMILIES
DEAL WITH THE FRUSTRATIONS
OF TRAVELING
WITH SMALL CHILDREN.
ANYONE WHO HAS KIDS
KNOWS HOW STRESSFUL IT CAN BE.
BY THE TIME YOU ARRIVE
AT THE AIRPORT,
YOU'RE DEALING WITH...
(laughs)
PULLING YOUR CUMBERSOME STROLLER
OUT OF THE TRUNK OF YOUR CAR...
(grunts) OH, CAN YOU HOLD
MY DAUGHTER?
OH, THANK YOU. OH, SORRY.
SURE. BE HAPPY TO.
(laughs)
OH.
BY THE TIME
YOU GET TO YOUR GATE,
YOU ARE TEARING
YOUR HAIRS OUT.
IT'S JUST A NIGHTMARE.
THAT'S WHY RANDY AND I
CAME UP WITH
THE RIDE ON CARRY ON.
(Robert laughs)
NOW THE RIDE ON CARRY ON
INSTANTLY CONVERTS
ANY WHEELED CARRY‐ON LUGGAGE
INTO A TRAVEL STROLLER.
IT CARRIES ANY CHILD
8 MONTHS TO 5 YEARS
SAFELY AND COMFORTABLY
THROUGH ANY AIRPORT,
TRAIN STATION, OR BUS STATION.
ONCE THERE,
YOUR LITTLE ONE HOPS OUT.
THE RIDE ON CARRY ON FOLDS
AGAINST THE TOP OF THE LUGGAGE.
IT EASILY STOWS
IN THE OVERHEAD BIN.
WHEN YOU GET
TO YOUR FINAL DESTINATION,
YOU PULL YOUR LUGGAGE DOWN,
YOU OPEN THE SEAT,
YOUR LITTLE ONE HOPS IN,
BUCKLE THE SEAT BELT,
AND AWAY YOU GO.
IT'S SO EASY.
WE'VE ALSO DESIGNED A HEADREST
FOR TALLER CHILDREN.
IT EASILY CONVERTS
INTO A HANDY TRAY TABLE
FOR EATING AND PLAYING
WHILE YOU WAIT.
NOW WE HAVE SOLD THOUSANDS
OF THESE ON THE INTERNET.
BUT WE NEED YOUR HELP GETTING
INTO THE RETAIL MARKET,
BECAUSE IT IS TIME FOR PEOPLE
TO TAKE THE STRESS OUT OF
TRAVELING WITH LITTLE ONES.
THE KIDS ABSOLUTELY LOVE
THE RIDE.
PARENTS LOVE THE CONVENIENCE.
ANY QUESTIONS?
YES. YOUR DAUGHTER'S
NOT BREATHING.
UH, Y‐YEAH, SHE'S QUIET.
SHE LOOKS‐‐SHE'S NOT‐‐
NO, SHE'S QUIET.
SHE'S NOT HAPPY BECAUSE SHE'S
NOT IN A RIDE ON CARRY ON.
I THOUGHT THE RIDE AND CARRY
MIGHT HAVE KILLED HER.
YEAH, EXACTLY.
EXACTLY. (laughs)
DARRYL, YOU HAVE A LAWN CHAIR
STRAPPED TO A PIECE OF LUGGAGE.
EXACTLY.
WELL, THAT'S WHERE WE STARTED.
MY FRIENDS AND PILOTS
AND FLIGHT ATTENDANTS
HELPED US DESIGN, UH,
THE WHOLE CHAIR.
THEY TOOK OUR PROTOTYPES
ON TRIPS.
AND IT JUST WAS PHENOMENAL‐‐
THE ATTENTION EVERYBODY GOT, UH,
WHEELING THROUGH THE AIRPORT‐‐
AND THAT'S WHEN WE KNEW
WE REALLY HAD SOMETHING.
AND WHAT AGE
WILL IT WORK?
8 MONTHS TO 5 YEARS.
WE, UM, MY DAUGHTER USED IT
TILL SHE WAS ABOUT 6. CHILDREN‐‐
IS THERE A SEAT BELT
ON IT?
THERE ABSOLUTELY IS A SEAT BELT
WITH A CROTCH STRAP, YEAH.
(Randy) 3‐POINT‐‐
ARE‐‐ARE YOU SELLING
THE CHAIR SEPARATELY,
AND THEN I STRAP IT ON
TO ANY PIECE OF LUGGAGE?
(Darryl and Randy) YES.
THAT'S HOW WE DESIGNED IT.
YOU SAID THOUSANDS
HAVE BEEN SOLD. HOW‐‐
WE SOLD UP‐‐ALMOST 20,000
OUT OF OUR HOUSE.
WHAT HAS BEEN YOUR NUMBER
IN THE LAST YEAR?
WE SOLD 2,000 CHAIRS
LAST YEAR.
AT WHAT PRICE?
(Darryl and Randy) $39.95.
AND WHAT DO YOU PAY
TO MAKE ONE?
$7.
(Barbara and Robert) $7?
(Darryl) YES.
GOOD MARGIN.
(Jeff) WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
I'M A POOL MAN,
IF YOU CAN BELIEVE IT.
WERE YOU MARRIED BEFORE AND HE‐‐
RANDY WAS THE POOL MAN?
NO.
NO, NO, THAT NEVER HAPPENS.
IT'S ONLY IN THE MOVIES.
OH. (laughs)
YEAH, YEAH, ONLY‐‐
ONLY IN THE MOVIES.
WE MET IN A BAR
IN FORT LAUDERDALE 19 YEARS AGO.
STICK WITH THE POOL MAN STORY.
IT'S BETTER.
(laughs) YEAH, EXACTLY.
EXACTLY. EXACTLY.
FIRST OF ALL, I‐I LOVE
A‐A WOMAN NAMED DARRYL.
(laughs) THANK YOU.
(laughs)
BECAUSE MY WIFE'S NAME
IS GREGG.
OH. I FEEL FOR HER, TOO.
(laughs)
MY FIRST THOUGHT IS, YOU'VE
NEVER HAD ANY SAFETY ISSUES?
BECAUSE I DO WORRY ABOUT
THE LIABILITY ON THIS.
ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S BEEN SAFETY TESTED
IN THE U. S. AND IN EUROPE.
PASSED ALL THE SAFETY TESTS.
UH, ALL THE CHAIRS WE'VE SOLD
HAVE HAD NO SAFETY ISSUES.
WE HAVEN'T EVEN HAD
ONE COMPLAINT.
HOW LONG HAVE YOU
BEEN DOING THIS?
WHEN WE CAME OUT
WITH THE IDEA‐‐
OUR SON WAS 2
WHEN WE THOUGHT OF IT.
HE'S 16 NOW, BUT WE‐‐
YOU'VE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR 14 YEARS?
THE FIRST FIVE OR SIX YEARS,
WE PLAYED WITH THE IDEA.
I HAD TO CONVINCE MY HUSBAND
TO INVEST IN THE PATENT.
YOU KNOW, THAT TOOK SOME TIME.
WE MORTGAGED THE HOUSE
FOR $150,000.
MORTGAGED THE HOUSE.
DID YOU MAKE BACK
THAT $150,000?
WE HAVE NO DEBT.
YEAH, WE HAVE NO DEBT.
WE'RE IN THE BLACK.
AND YOU MADE IT BACK
WITH THE CHAIRS?
(Darryl and Randy) YES.
(Robert)
WOW. GOOD FOR YOU.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO
WITH THE $50,000?
PRODUCT AWARENESS.
GET OUR WEB SITE‐‐
IT'S NOT OPTIMIZED AT ALL.
OPTIMIZE THE WEB SITE.
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
IT EXISTS.
LET'S GET BACK TO THE PATH
TO RICHES HERE.
FORGET ALL THIS "YOU DO
YOUR OWN RETAIL" STUFF.
YOU KNOW
THAT'S A SLAUGHTERFEST.
WE REALLY THOUGHT THAT, UM,
GETTING INTO THE RETAIL MARKET
WOULD BE THE WAY TO GO.
WE WANT PEOPLE
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BUY THIS PRODUCT.
AS A PARENT,
I WOULD BE INTERESTED
TO HAVE A‐A MAJOR LUGGAGE
MANUFACTURER...
RIGHT.
HAVE‐‐HAVE A MODEL
WHERE THIS IS BUILT IN.
THE REALITY IS, THOUGH,
LUGGAGE IS VERY EXPENSIVE.
IS SOMEBODY GONNA BUY
A SPECIAL PIECE OF LUGGAGE
JUST TO HAUL
THEIR CHILDREN AROUND?
WHAT IF THEIR CHILDREN
AREN'T TRAVELING WITH THEM?
(Kevin) I'LL TELL YOU, RANDY...
SO‐‐
YOU COULD ADD ONE FEATURE
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
MAKE IT SO I COULD CHECK
THE KID WITH THE LUGGAGE.
(laughs)
AND HOW MUCH INVENTORY
DO YOU HAVE?
(Darryl and Randy) ZERO.
HOW MANY ORDERS
DO YOU HAVE PENDING?
WE HAVE 2,000 RIGHT NOW,
PENDING‐‐
SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT THERE
ARE RETAILERS OUT THERE
OR SOMEBODY EXISTING SAYING
THAT WE NEED 2,000 OF THESE?
(Darryl and Randy) YES.
I THINK YOU'VE GOT
A GREAT IDEA.
AND THAT'S 90% OF IT.
WHEN WE HEARD YOU MIGHT BE ON,
WE SAID,
YOU KNOW YOU'RE A REDNECK
WHEN YOUR KIDS
ARE STRAPPED TO YOUR LUGGAGE
GOING THROUGH THE AIRPORT.
(Robert laughs) YEAH.
THAT'S NOT EVEN YOU MIGHT BE.
YOU ARE. YOU ARE AT THAT POINT.
(all laugh)
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I APPRECIATE YOUR ENTHUSIASM.
I‐I AM JUST NOT
INTO THIS BUSINESS.
I'M OUT.
LOVE THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
HOLDING HANDS UP THERE.
THAT'S GREAT.
FOR ME, THE PATH TO WHAT YOU
NEED TO DO IS SO OBVIOUS.
AND YOU MAY NOT AGREE WITH ME,
BUT I THINK
IT'S A LICENSING IDEA.
I DON'T THINK YOU NEED
TO BE HERE ASKING FOR MONEY.
I WOULD LICENSE IT.
I'M OUT.
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO,
"BUSINESSWEEK"
PICKED THIS
AS ONE OF THEIR TOP 25 BEST...
TOP...
(Darryl and Randy)
NEW PRODUCTS OF THE YEAR.
AND WE WERE THE ONLY COMPANY
THAT WASN'T FORTUNE 500.
FORTUNE 500.
I'D LIKE TO PUT AN OFFER
ON THE TABLE.
$50,000, EXACTLY AS YOU STATED,
FOR 25%,
WITH THE ONLY CONTINGENCY BEING
THAT WE BRAND THAT TRAY
WITH YOUR RIDE ON CARRY ON,
BIG AND BOLD.
I THINK IT'S A CATALOG SALE.
I THINK IT'S A RETAIL SALE.
I DON'T GO ALONG
WITH THE WAY OF THINKING
THAT IT SHOULD BE SOLD
TO A LUGGAGE COMPANY.
I THINK IT'S‐‐IT'S SEPARATE.
WELL, I LOVE‐‐I LOVE
THE NEGOTIATION, BARBARA...
YEAH. WHAT?
WHERE YOU OFFER 'EM EXACTLY
WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR.
HEY, IT'S WORTH IT.
I COULD SEE THIS THING
SELLING LIKE HOTCAKES.
(Darryl) OH, ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK
YOU NEED HELP MARKETING.
OH, THAT'S WHAT WE NEED.
WE DEFINITELY DO.
WE NEED YOUR HELP.
WE ARE WORKING
FULL‐TIME JOBS‐‐
YOU ARE ADORABLE TOGETHER.
(Darryl laughs) THANK YOU.
OKAY, DARRYL AND RANDY,
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
IT GOES LIKE THIS.
TWO SHARKS ARE OUT.
BARBARA HAS OFFERED
RANDY AND DARRYL $50,000
FOR 25% OF THE COMPANY,
WHICH IS WHAT
THEY ORIGINALLY ASKED FOR.
BUT KEVIN HAS
A COMPETING OFFER.
OKAY, DARRYL AND RANDY,
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER,
AND IT GOES LIKE THIS‐‐
INSTEAD OF, UM, TAKING 25%,
I'M WILLING TO DO IT
FOR 20%, BUT...
STOP MANUFACTURING
ANY OF THIS ON YOUR OWN.
STOP SELLING IT
ON THE INTERNET COMPLETELY.
AND YOU USE THOSE DOLLARS
TO GO FIND ME
TWO DIFFERENT MANUFACTURERS
THAT MAKE THOSE BAGS
THAT OWN 80% SHARE
OF THE MARKET,
'CAUSE I DON'T WANT
TO DO THE WORK.
I JUST WANT YOU
TO BRING THEM TO ME,
AND I'LL NEGOTIATE
THE LICENSE DEAL.
WHEN THEY'RE READY TO NEGOTIATE,
YOU GIVE ME THEIR PHONE NUMBER,
AND YOU'LL KEEP 80%,
AND I'LL TAKE
20% OF EVERYTHING FOREVER.
YOU'RE GONNA SAY, "WOW.
"I COULD TAKE
UNCLE KEVIN'S $50,000,
LIVE OFF THAT"‐‐
CAN YOU EVEN IMAGINE
CALLING THIS GUY "UNCLE KEVIN"?
(Darryl laughs)
I THOUGHT HE‐‐
I THOUGHT HE WAS MEAN KEVIN.
(Kevin) NO, I‐‐
I'LL LET YOU IN ON A SECRET.
EVERYBODY CALLS ME
MR. WONDERFUL.
OH, THERE WE GO.
'CAUSE I DON'T ACTUALLY KNOW
THE LUGGAGE BUSINESS, GUYS,
BUT I CERTAINLY KNOW
HOW TO NEGOTIATE A LICENSE DEAL.
I'M VERY GOOD AT THAT.
I THOUGHT YOU KNEW EVERYTHING
ABOUT EVERY BUSINESS.
NO, BUT I'M WILLING
TO ADMIT WHAT I DON'T KNOW,
ROBERT, UNLIKE YOU.
I THINK BARBARA'S GIVING YOU
A GREAT DEAL,
AND I THAT HE'S GIVING YOU
A SUCKER DEAL. UM, I'M OUT.
OH, LISTEN TO THAT.
HE BRINGS NO MONEY.
HE MAKES NOISE. TYPICAL.
OKAY, SO YOU HAVE TWO OFFERS.
BARBARA KEEPS YOU
IN A MANUFACTURING HELLHOLE.
FOR ME, IT'S A SMALL,
FOCUSED PERIOD OF TIME
WHERE YOU GO GET ME
TWO MANUFACTURERS,
GET ME THE PHONE NUMBER
OF THE LICENSING GUY IN EACH,
AND I'LL COME HOME
WITH THE DEAL.
(Barbara) YOU KNOW,
HE'S MAKING A LICENSING DEAL
SOUND LIKE IT'S ROCKET SCIENCE.
IT REALLY ISN'T.
ANY HALF‐DECENT ATTORNEY
COULD NEGOTIATE THAT DEAL.
DON'T BE WOWED
BY HIS FANCY WORDS.
JUST LOOK AT THIS GUY.
LOOK WHAT HE LOOKS LIKE.
(laughter)
AND THINK, DO YOU WANT TO DO
BUSINESS WITH THIS GUY?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
EXACTLY. THAT'S WHY
THEY CALL ME MR. WONDERFUL,
BECAUSE EVERY DEAL THAT COMES
OUT OF MY LIPS IS WONDERFUL,
IF YOU REALLY THINK ABOUT IT.
RIGHT, RIGHT.
AND BY THE WAY, TO KEVIN'S
POINT ABOUT LICENSING,
I'M NOT RULING THAT OUT.
I JUST DON'T LIKE PUTTING
ALL MY EGGS IN ONE BASKET
BECAUSE WHAT YOU NEED MORE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE IS MARKETING HELP.
RIGHT. CORRECT.
OKAY, THAT'S ENOUGH.
IT'S TIME TO MAKE A DECISION.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
WE WANT TO GO WITH BARBARA.
WE THINK WE'LL HAVE FUN
WORKING WITH BARBARA.
BUT I STILL LOVE YOU, KEVIN.
(Barbara) RIGHT DECISION.
(Kevin)
OH, YOU BROKE MY HEART.
MY PLEASURE. GREAT JOB.
YAY! THANK YOU, BARBARA! WE'RE
GONNA HAVE FUN WORKING TOGETHER.
(Darryl) THANK YOU SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
(sighs)
THANK YOU.
WHOO‐HOO!
(laughs)
AWESOME.
WHEW.
(Daymond) GOOD DEAL, BARBARA.
(Barbara) YOU KNOW,
THE MAIN POINT IS,
IS THAT NOBODY WANTS
TO DO BUSINESS WITH YOU.
HAVE YOU GOTTEN ON TO THAT?
I‐‐YOU KNOW,
MY DEALS ARE GOOD.
WHEN THEY ACTUALLY HAPPEN...
YEAH.
THEY MAKE MONEY,
AND THAT'S ALL THAT MATTERS.
EVERYBODY SAYS "NO, THANK YOU.
NO, THANK YOU. NO, THANK YOU."
NO, BARBARA, BECAUSE I THINK
WHEN THEY FINALLY FIGURE IT OUT
AFTER TWO YEARS
OF SWEATING IT OUT
TRYING TO MANUFACTURE
THIS STUFF,
THEY'LL SAY, "I WISH I'D DONE
THAT DEAL WITH UNCLE KEVIN."
I'M SURE.
I'M SURE YOU'RE RIGHT.
EXACTLY. I‐I KNOW I'M RIGHT.
KEVIN, WHO EXACTLY IS CALLING
YOU MR. WONDERFUL, BY THE WAY?
YOU ARE RIGHT NOW.
(all laugh)
WE ARE SO EXCITED THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO MAKE A DEAL,
BUT WE ARE EVEN MORE EXCITED
FOR THE KIDS OF AMERICA
THAT CAN FINALLY HAVE FUN
TRAVELING THROUGH AN AIRPORT.
YEAH.
(laughs)
♪♪♪
LAST SEASON,
WE SAW TIFFANY KRUMINS
STRIKE A $50,000 DEAL
WITH BARBARA CORCORAN
FOR HER CHILDREN'S MEDICINE
DISPENSER AVA THE ELEPHANT.
LET'S SEE WHAT SHE'S UP TO NOW.
♪♪♪
A YEAR AGO,
I WALKED INTO THE SHARK TANK
WITH A HAND‐MOLDED PROTOTYPE
AND JUST AN IDEA.
AND I NEVER WOULD'VE THOUGHT
IT WOULD TURN INTO SOMETHING
THIS BIG.
AND NOW 75,000 AVA THE ELEPHANTS
JUST ARRIVED FROM
OUR MANUFACTURER IN CHINA.
WE'RE GETTING READY
TO BOX THEM UP
AND SEND THEM OUT TO CVS STORES
ALL ACROSS THE NATION.
NOW MILLIONS OF PARENTS
CARING FOR MILLIONS OF KIDS
ARE GOING TO HAVE
MY LITTLE AVA THE ELEPHANT
TO HELP WITH MEDICINE TIME.
CVS IS SO EXCITED
ABOUT AVA THE ELEPHANT,
THEY'RE GONNA PUT HER PICTURE
ON EVERY PRESCRIPTION BAG
FOR CHILDREN.
A YEAR AGO, I NEVER WOULD'VE
IMAGINED WALKING INTO A STORE
AND SEEING MY AVA THE ELEPHANT
ON THE SHELVES.
YES. OH, MY GOD. I CAN'T
BELIEVE IT'S FINALLY HERE.
WE'RE ON TRACK TO HAVE OVER
2 AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS
IN SALES
IN JUST OUR FIRST YEAR.
I NEVER COULD'VE DONE THIS
WITHOUT BARBARA CORCORAN
AND HER INVESTMENT.
♪♪♪
I'M KEN HOWELL,
AND THE NAME OF MY BUSINESS
IS UNCLE ZIP'S BEEF JERKY.
WHAT MAKES MY BEEF JERKY
SO SPECIAL‐‐
IT COMES FROM A FAMILY RECIPE.
MINE'S FRESH AND 100% NATURAL.
HEY! ANYBODY NEED JERKY?!
PEOPLE IN THE TOWN,
THEY ABSOLUTELY LOVE MY JERKY.
THEY COME TO THE SPORTING EVENTS
THAT I GO TO, THEY'RE ALWAYS,
"UNCLE ZIP! HEY. WHAT'S GOING
ON? GIVE ME SOME JERKY.
GIVE ME SOME JERKY."
HEY!
BASICALLY,
I'M A ONE‐MAN BAND.
UNCLE ZIP!
WHAT'S HAPPENIN', Y'ALL?
THIS ISN'T JUST A BUSINESS
TO ME. THIS IS A PASSION.
MY DAD ORIGINALLY STARTED
THE BUSINESS.
HE WAS THE ORIGINAL UNCLE ZIP.
ABOUT FIVE, SIX YEARS AGO,
HE PASSED AWAY.
SO I WANT TO CONTINUE ON
HIS LEGACY AND MAKE HIM PROUD.
I KNOW MY BUSINESS CAN BE
REALLY SUCCESSFUL
AND JUST WITH A LITTLE BIT
OF HELP,
I CAN TAKE IT
FROM A HOMETOWN BUSINESS
TO A NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED BRAND
IN STORES EVERYWHERE,
ALL ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
♪♪♪
HI. MY NAME'S KEN HOWELL.
I'M FROM
FAYETTEVILLE, NORTH CAROLINA,
AND THE NAME OF MY COMPANY
IS UNCLE ZIP'S BEEF JERKY.
NOW I'M ASKING
FOR A $25,000 INVESTMENT
FOR A 20% PARTNERSHIP
IN MY COMPANY.
NOW WHAT MAKES UNCLE ZIP'S
BEEF JERKY BETTER
THAN ANY OTHER
BEEF JERKY OUT THERE?
IT'S THE FRESH TASTE.
YOU SEE, I DON'T USE
ANY ADDITIVES, NO PRESERVATIVES.
A LOT OF PEOPLE, WHEN THEY HAVE
THAT MASS‐PRODUCED STUFF,
THEY SAY IT'S TOUGH
AND THEY TASTE
THAT CHEMICAL TASTE, YOU KNOW,
THAT CHEMICAL BLAH TASTE.
MINE IS FRESH, FRESH MADE.
NOW I GOT A SAMPLE
IF YOU WANT SOME.
HERE YOU GO.
YOU KNOW, I TRIED THAT
JEFF FOXWORTHY BEEF JERKY.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF IT,
ROBERT?
WELL, I LOVED IT, JEFF.
HOW DOES THIS COMPARE?
IT IS REALLY, HANDS DOWN‐‐
CAREFUL NOW, KEN.
(laughs)
(Ken) EVERYBODY LOVES
THE BEEF JERKY.
WHAT'S THE STORY? IS THIS
THE BEST YOU'VE EVER EATEN?
IT'S GOOD, VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
KEN, WHY IS IT CALLED
UNCLE ZIP?
MY FATHER WAS ACTUALLY
IN THE YELLOW PAGE SALES,
AND HE WAS REALLY, REALLY GOOD.
HE COULD ZIP IN, ZIP OUT
WITH A SALE, SO ZIP STUCK.
WELL, HE ORIGINALLY STARTED
THE BEEF JERKY. HE WAS LIKE,
"WELL, YOU KNOW, WE'RE GONNA DO
ZIP'S BEEF JERKY."
SO I SAID, "YEAH, YEAH,"
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN, HE GOES,
"YEAH, GOOD OL' UNCLE ZIP,"
AND I WENT... "(gasps)
THAT'S IT.
UNCLE ZIP'S BEEF JERKY."
I SAID,
"THAT'D BE PERFECT."
NOW EVERYBODY KNOWS ME AS EITHER
UNCLE ZIP OR JERKY MAN.
HONESTLY, I CAN GO WALKING INTO
A‐ANY STORE,
AND I'LL HEAR, "JERKY MAN.
HEY, HEY, JERKY MAN. JERKY MAN.
JERKY MAN."
(sharks laugh)
I'LL TELL YOU SOMETHING.
THIS IS PRETTY GOOD.
THANK YOU.
HOW DOES IT STAY IN THE PACKAGE
WITHOUT PRESERVATIVES,
WITHOUT CHEMICALS?
DOES IT GO BAD RIGHT AWAY?
NO, IT DOESN'T GO BAD
RIGHT AWAY,
BUT HERE'S THE THING,
I PUT ABOUT A TWO MONTH,
UM, SHELF LIFE ON IT.
ISN'T THAT A PROBLEM?
DOESN'T THAT BEEF JERKY
STAY ON FOR YEARS
ON THE SHELF?
EXACTLY, AND THE REASON WHY
IT DOES STAY ON FOR YEARS
IS BECAUSE OF THOSE‐‐
LIKE I SAID BEFORE,
IS THOSE CHEMICALS
THAT ARE IN THERE,
AND THAT'S ALL
YOU'RE TASTING.
HOW MUCH SALES HAVE YOU HAD
IN THE LAST YEAR?
RIGHT. WELL, UNFORTUNATELY...
IN THE LAST‐‐IN THE LAST‐‐
OH! YOU'RE STARTING OFF
WITH "UNFORTUNATELY"? LET'S GO.
WELL, IN THE LAST COUPLE OF‐‐
ACTUALLY, THE LAST SEVEN YEARS,
I‐I'VE BEEN KINDA DOWN
FOR THE SIMPLE FACT THAT
I LOST MY‐‐I LOST MY FATHER.
I'M ALMOST
IN A REBUILDING STAGE.
YOU'VE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR SEVEN YEARS?
I‐I'VE BEEN DOING IT FOR
RIGHT AT TEN YEARS NOW.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
THE HIGHEST SALES,
I WAS RIGHT AT $100,000.
THAT WAS RIGHT BEFORE
MY DAD TOOK ILL.
AND WHAT WERE YOUR SALES
LAST YEAR?
UM, IT WAS‐‐
YOU'RE PROBABLY LOOKING‐‐
IT WAS ABOUT
$40,000 OR $50,000.
NOW WHAT DO YOU WANT
THE $25,000 FOR, KEN?
THE $25,000 IS‐‐WE'RE GONNA
START OUT BY UPGRADING
THE‐‐THE, UM,
PROCESSING FACILITY
I ALREADY HAVE.
THAT'S GONNA ALLOW US
TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND
INTO THESE LARGER MARKETS.
ONCE WE GET IN THERE, WE'LL HAVE
SMALL PROCESSING PLANTS.
AND YOU'RE LOOKING
TO OPEN UP ON OF THESE,
YOU'RE LOOKING ABOUT $60,000,
AND THAT'S THE‐‐
(Robert) BUT, KEN,
ISN'T THAT JUST CRAZY?
EVERY TIME YOU OPEN UP
A NEW REGION,
YOU NEED
A NEW PROCESSING PLANT?
WELL, THAT‐‐THAT NEW REGION
IS GONNA BE ABLE TO PUT
FRESH BEEF JERKY ON THE SHELF
THAT OTHERWISE HAS BEEN
SITTING THERE FOR A YEAR.
AND THAT'S THE THING‐‐
NOBODY KNOWS REALLY FRESH
BEEF JERKY.
I DON'T THINK
THE PROBLEM IS GONNA BE
HAVING THE LOCAL
PROCESSING PLANT.
I DON'T THINK YOUR SHELF LIFE
IS LONG ENOUGH.
YOU CAN'T BE MAKING A LIVING
ON‐‐ON THIS.
WELL, I‐I DO HAVE
A LITTLE PART‐TIME‐‐
I GOT A CARPET BUSINESS
THAT I DO‐‐DO PART‐TIME, TOO.
KEN, IT'S BEEN TEN YEARS,
AND YOU'RE STILL NOT MAKING
A LIVING DOING IT.
I'M STRUGGLING TO UNDERSTAND
WHY YOU'RE STILL DOING IT.
ARE YOU STILL DOING IT
BECAUSE IT'S A BUSINESS?
IS THIS SOME KIND OF A TRIBUTE
TO YOUR DAD?
IT DOES LEAN
A LITTLE BIT TOWARDS,
THAT WAS MY DAD,
AND HE WANTED THE BUSINESS.
AND WE TALKED MANY TIMES
ABOUT WANTING
TO PUT IT ON SHELVES.
AND I JUST‐‐I JUST KNOW
I CAN DO IT.
JUST LIKE ANY BUSINESS, WHEN
THEY HIT THAT‐‐THAT LITTLE HUMP,
THEY JUST NEED THAT LITTLE BOOST
OF CAPITAL TO GET ROLLING AGAIN.
AND I‐‐AND I REALLY THINK
THIS RIGHT HERE,
PARTNERING UP WITH YOU GUYS‐‐
ONE OF YOU, TWO OF YOU,
ALL OF YOU‐‐
I REALLY THINK THAT WE CAN
GET THIS BACK‐‐BACK ON TRACK
AND GET GOING AGAIN.
(Robert) KEN,
WE ALL HAVE A DREAM.
BUT NOT ONLY DOES EVERY DREAM
HAVE A PRICE,
EVERY DREAM HAS A SHELF LIFE,
JUST LIKE YOUR BEEF JERKY.
RIGHT.
THIS ISN'T
AN INVESTABLE BUSINESS.
I'M OUT.
OKAY. OKAY.
THIS IS A SMALL BUSINESS,
NOT AN INVESTMENT.
I'M OUT.
I'M GONNA TELL IT
THE WAY IT IS.
LOOK, I LOVE THE STORY,
I LOVE THE PAST,
I LOVE ALL THAT STUFF,
BUT I'M AN INVESTOR, ALL RIGHT?
WHAT YOU PRESENTED
IS A SMALL, REGIONAL BRAND‐‐
A MICRO BRAND, REALLY SMALL.
IT'S GOOD. I ATE IT.
IT IS FRESH. THAT'S GREAT.
THE TROUBLE IS,
YOU'RE NOT SELLING THAT MUCH.
I'M OUT.
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
KEN ONLY HAS TWO MORE CHANCES
TO MAKE A DEAL.
ALL RIGHT, KEN, I'M GONNA‐‐
I'M GONNA SAY THIS.
YOU'VE GOT A GOOD PRODUCT.
OKAY.
IT TASTES FRESH.
IT TASTES GOOD.
I'M OUT...
BUT MAINLY BECAUSE
I'M IN THE SAME BUSINESS.
RIGHT, RIGHT.
BUT I THINK
YOU'VE GOT SOMETHING HERE
THAT YOU COULD MAKE A GOOD
LIVING ON WITH THE RIGHT THINGS.
I DON'T THINK
IT'S BIG ENOUGH YET
FOR OTHER PEOPLE TO COME IN
AND INVEST IN IT,
BUT YOUR PRODUCT'S GOOD ENOUGH
THAT YOU COULD MAKE
A GOOD LIVING ON IT.
YOU KNOW, YOU MADE $100,000
IN YOUR THIRD YEAR
IN THE BUSINESS, OKAY?
THEN YOU CAME THROUGH
YEARS OF HARDSHIP
FOR ONE REASON OR THE OTHER.
MUCH MORE DIFFICULT OBSTACLES
TO OVERCOME
THAN SELLING BEEF JERKY.
RIGHT.
THERE'S NO HELP YOU NEED
FROM ANYBODY
TO GET THIS BACK ON THE ROAD.
YOU'VE GOT IT IN YOU.
I DON'T THINK YOU NEED US HERE.
YOU'RE VERY CAPABLE
OF GETTING BACK ON YOUR FEET,
SO I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT. THANKS, Y'ALL.
I APPRECIATE IT.
WE'LL SEE YA. (sighs)
(groans)
(chuckles)
I'M JUST
GONNA KEEP PRESSIN' ON,
BECAUSE THAT‐‐
I‐I KNOW THIS WILL MAKE IT.
WHEW.
OH.
AND...
(voice breaking)
AND I KNOW THEY SAID THAT,
ARE YOU HOLDING ON BECAUSE...
WHEW.
MAYBE I AM.
MAYBE I AM HOLDING ON
'CAUSE OF MY DAD.
(sniffles)
BUT IT'S SOMETHING
I LOVE TO DO, TOO.
(sniffles) I JUST...
(sniffles)
I'M NOT GON' QUIT.
♪♪♪
MY NAME IS MIKE.
MY NAME'S SHON.
WE'RE FROM PARKLAND, FLORIDA.
WE'RE THE FOUNDERS OF THE NEXT
GREAT AMERICAN CLOTHING COMPANY,
HillBilly BRAND.
THE TERM "HILLBILLY" IS NOT
WHAT IT USED TO BE.
IT REPRESENTS THE COUNTRY
LIFESTYLE, OUTDOOR LIVING.
PLEASE ARE PROUD TO WEAR IT.
IT'S A BADGE OF HONOR.
OUR WIVES THOUGHT
WE WERE CRAZY
WHEN WE FIRST STARTED
THIS COMPANY.
BUT AFTER SELLING OUT
AT OUR FIRST EVENT,
THEY STARTED TO COME AROUND.
WELL, THEY STILL THINK
WE'RE CRAZY,
BUT NOW THEY'RE TRUE BELIEVERS.
RIGHT NOW, THE MAJORITY
OF OUR SALES
ARE COMING FROM EVENTS LIKE
RODEOS, MUD FESTS, CONCERTS.
(cheering)
WHEN PEOPLE PASS BY OUR TENT
TO SEE OUR BRAND
FOR THE FIRST TIME,
IT'S ALWAYS THE SAME REACTION.
THEY'RE SMILING,
THEY'RE MOUTHS ARE OPEN,
THEY'RE POSING FOR PICTURES
IN FRONT OF OUR SIGN.
I MEAN, PEOPLE JUST LOVE
THE BRAND.
WHEN WE SET UP AT AN EVENT,
WE BRING THE PARTY.
WE HAVE THE COUNTRY MUSIC
CRANKIN',
WE'VE GOT
THE HillBilly HOTTIES THERE.
WE'VE GOT THE CROWD
AT THE BOOTH,
AND EVERYBODY'S HAVING
A GOOD TIME.
AND WE'RE BRINGING THAT
SAME PARTY TO THE SHARK TANK.
(5th Gear's "HillBilly
Saturday Night" playing)
♪ HillBilly,
HillBilly SATURDAY NIGHT ♪
♪ HillBilly... ♪
YEAH, I WANT THE CAMO.
THANK YOU.
(Robert) CAN I HAVE
A COWBOY HAT?
(Daymond) THANK YOU.
♪♪♪
YOU LOOK RIDICULOUS.
(laughs)
HI, MY NAME'S SHON LEES. THIS IS
MY PARTNER MIKE ABBATICCHIO.
AND WE'RE CO‐OWNERS
OF HillBilly BRAND,
A COUNTRY LIFESTYLE
CLOTHING COMPANY.
WE ARE HERE TO ASK
FOR A $50,000 INVESTMENT
FOR A 25% EQUITY STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
MIKE AND I HAVE KNOWN EACH OTHER
SINCE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
WE WERE ALWAYS LOOKING FOR
A BUSINESS TO START,
BUT WE NEVER REALLY FOUND ONE WE
ENJOYED DOING IN OUR SPARE TIME.
THAT ALL CHANGED ON A SKI TRIP
TO COLORADO.
ON THAT TRIP, MIKE SHOWED ME
THE HillBilly LOGO HE CREATED,
AND I THOUGHT IT WAS GREAT.
WE WENT TO OUR FIRST EVENT,
A SMALL LOCAL RODEO,
AND WE SOLD EVERYTHING
WE BROUGHT IN FOUR HOURS.
WE KNEW WE WERE
ONTO SOMETHING BIG.
NOW THE TERM "HILLBILLY"
IS NOT WHAT IT USED TO BE.
PEOPLE LOVE THE BRAND.
THEY WEAR IT PROUD.
IT REPRESENTS THEIR LIFESTYLE‐‐
THE COUNTRY LIFESTYLE.
I WANT YOU TO THINK OUTDOORS‐‐
HUNTING, FISHING, SKIING,
AND MORE. AND COUNTRY MUSIC
AND NASCAR FANS ARE AMONG
THE MOST LOYAL CONSUMERS.
AND THERE'S MILLIONS OF 'EM,
SO THIS IS JUST
THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
T‐SHIRTS, HATS, AND TANK TOPS
ARE ONLY THE BEGINNING.
OUR CUSTOMERS ARE ASKING US
FOR BLUE JEANS, BATHING SUITS,
FISHING GEAR, HUNTING GEAR,
AND BACKPACKS.
WE CAN PUT THIS LOGO
ON JUST ABOUT ANYTHING.
I'M TELLING YOU GUYS,
THE PRODUCT AND LICENSING
OPPORTUNITIES ARE ENDLESS.
WITH THE RIGHT MANUFACTURING,
DISTRIBUTION, AND MARKETING,
HillBilly BRAND WILL BE
A HOUSEHOLD NAME.
EVERYBODY'S GOT A LITTLE
HILLBILLY IN 'EM. FIND YOURS.
FIND YOURS. AND, JEFF,
YOU MIGHT BE A REDNECK,
BUT WE KNOW YOU GOT
A LITTLE HILLBILLY IN YOU.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
A HILLBILLY AND A REDNECK?
I'VE ALWAYS DEFINED REDNECK
AS A GLORIOUS ABSENCE
OF SOPHISTICATION.
(sharks laugh)
AND IT REALLY DIDN'T MATTER
HOW MUCH MONEY YOU HAD.
RIGHT.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW,
I'VE KNOWN RICH GUYS
THAT CAME HOME
AND POPPED A BEER
AND SAT OUT ON THE PORCH
AND WATCHED THE BUG ZAPPER.
(laughs)
I MEAN,
THAT'S QUALITY ENTERTAINMENT.
I‐I MEAN, I THINK
IT'S THE SAME ATTITUDE.
IT'S A FUN, "DON'T WORRY ABOUT
TOO MANY THINGS" KINDA ATTITUDE.
AND‐‐AND I LIKED YOUR STUFF.
GUYS, DO YOU HAVE ANY SALES?
YES. (chuckles)
YES. SO FAR,
WE'VE SOLD ABOUT $271,000
IN A LITTLE OVER
3 AND A HALF YEARS.
NEVER ANSWER A SALES QUESTION
WITH WHAT YOU'VE SOLD
OVER THREE YEARS.
YEP.
THAT ALWAYS MAKES ME THINK
YOUR SALES AREN'T VERY GOOD.
WHAT'D YOU SELL
IN THE LAST 12 MONTHS?
SO FAR,
ABOUT $50,000 THIS YEAR,
WE'RE ON TRACK TO DO
$60,000.
DO YOU HAVE ANY DISTRIBUTION?
WHERE'S THIS STUFF SOLD?
UH, WE DO EVENT SALES.
WE DO ABOUT 12 A YEAR.
ONE A MONTH.
YOU HAVE NO RETAIL DISTRIBUTION.
WELL, WE JUST ACTUALLY SIGNED
A VENDOR AGREEMENT
WITH SPORTS AUTHORITY, AND WE'RE
GONNA START IN APPROXIMATELY
30 STORES IN THE SOUTHEAST.
AND WE GOT PICKED UP
BY A DISTRIBUTION
COMPANY CALLED BARJAN,
WHICH DISTRIBUTE PRODUCTS
TO ALL THE TRAVEL PLAZAS
AND TRUCK STOPS
ACROSS THE NATION.
SO YOU OWN THE NAME HillBilly?
YES. WE ACT‐‐WE OWN‐‐
IN WHAT CATEGORIES?
WE OWN‐‐WE OWN THE BRAND
AS FAR AS THE DESIGN LOGO
AND WE OWN JUST THE WORD
"HillBilly" FOR APPAREL‐‐
BELTS, T‐SHIRTS, HATS.
AND WE HAVE THREE TRADEMARKS
IN THE U. S. AND ONE IN CANADA.
(Robert) MIKE,
HERE'S MY CHALLENGE WITH IT.
HOW WOULD YOU EVER
GET YOUR NAME OUT THERE?
LIKE, THE ADVERTISING COSTS
TO BUILD A BRAND,
IF YOU'RE NOT A BRAND ALREADY,
WOULD COST MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
YOU'RE ASKING FOR $50,000.
WELL, HERE'S‐‐HERE'S WHAT
WE'VE DONE SO FAR.
WE'VE CLOSELY ALIGNED OURSELVES
WITH COUNTRY MUSIC.
YOU KNOW, WE GO OUT
TO THE CONCERTS,
WE SET UP OUR TENT,
AND MOST OF THE TIME,
WE SELL MORE T‐SHIRTS
THAN THE ARTISTS DO.
SO IN A TYPICAL EVENT, HOW MANY
T‐SHIRTS WOULD YOU SELL?
IT'S IT'S A BIG CONCERT, UM,
IF IT'S 20,000 PEOPLE,
WE CAN SELL AS MUCH AS $10,000.
BUT THAT‐‐THAT'S NOT
A NET NUMBER
BECAUSE I‐I MEAN, I SELL
T‐SHIRTS AT CONCERTS...
YES.
AND I KNOW THAT THE VENUES
BEAT YOU OVER THE HEAD.
I MEAN, THERE'S KIND OF A LOW
MARGIN ON THAT, ISN'T THERE?
WELL, IT DEPENDS. I MEAN,
IF IT'S‐‐SOME‐‐SOME EVENTS,
IT'S $100 TO GET IN.
SOME, IT'S $1,000.
ARE YOU GONNA MAKE A PROFIT
ON THAT?
YEAH, WELL,
WE'RE CASH FLOW‐POSITIVE,
ABOUT IT OVER $7,000
FOR THE YEAR.
WE'VE BEEN PUTTING EVERYTHING
BACK INTO THE BUSINESS.
BUT YOU DON'T
PAY YOURSELVES ANYTHING.
NO, NOT YET.
SO YOUR BUSINESS MAKES
ABOUT $7,000.
NOT REALLY. THEY DON'T
PAY THEMSELVES ANYTHING.
SO, SHON, THE‐‐THE $50,000
YOU'RE ASKING FOR,
WHAT‐‐WHAT WOULD YOU USE
THAT FOR?
WELL, WE WANNA START ATTENDING
THE TRADE SHOWS
TO GET IT
IN FRONT OF THE BUYERS
AND WE WANNA EXPAND OUR
TRADEMARKS INTO OUR COUNTRIES.
I MEAN, WE WANNA TAKE OUR PARTY
TO THE TRADE SHOW.
YOU CAN'T JUST HAVE ONE TABLE
AND TWO GUYS SITTING BEHIND IT,
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE WHEN
WE SELL THIS STUFF,
WE GOT THE MUSIC BLASTING,
WE THROW IMPROMPTU CONCERTS.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE ARTISTS
COME INTO OUR TENT.
YOU KNOW,
SO IT IS A HUGE PARTY,
AND‐‐AND I THINK THAT'S WHY
WE HAVE SUCH A GREAT FOLLOWING.
NOW YOU'RE ASKING FOR $50,000
FOR 25% OF THE BUSINESS.
THAT MEANS YOU'RE VALUATING
YOUR BUSINESS AT $200,000.
ON $7,000 IN PROFIT.
NO PROFIT. THERE'S NO PROFIT.
STOP SAYING THAT.
OH, YOU'RE RIGHT.
ON NO PROFIT.
WE BASED THAT
ON THE $60,000 IN SALES,
2 AND A HALF TIMES EARNINGS,
PLUS $50,000 VALUE ON
THE 4 TRADEMARKS WE'RE HOLDING.
I THINK YOU WERE SMART ENOUGH
TO UNDERSTAND
THE POWER OF THE MARK.
THAT RIGHT THERE IS
A GREAT BUSINESS ITSELF.
SO YOU GONNA WRITE A CHECK?
ARE YOU SELLING SOMETHING?
THEN MIND YOUR BUSINESS.
WHY NOT LICENSE THIS OUT
TO SOMEBODY...
(O'Leary) EXACTLY.
AND LET THEM GO AFTER
THE BIG RETAILERS?
AND‐‐AND YOU REAP
THE BENEFITS.
THAT'S DEFINITELY SOMETHING
THAT WE WANTED TO EXPLORE.
I MEAN, WE'VE ALREADY SIGNED
A LICENSING DEAL
WITH A CANADIAN
RECORD COMPANY.
AND THEY'RE GONNA START
PACKAGING IT WITH THEIR MUSIC
AND THEIR ARTISTS, AND SELLING
IT IN A HUNDRED HMV STORES,
YOU KNOW, COMING UP
IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS.
(O'Leary) OKAY, HERE'S WHAT
I TAKE FROM THIS.
NOW YOU'VE COME OUT HERE
AND SAID,
"LOOK, WE'RE SMART ENOUGH
TO KNOW
"THAT THE ONLY THING OF VALUE
WE HAVE IS OUR MARK‐‐
"OUR BRAND HillBilly.
"WE'RE SO SMART THAT WE'VE GOT
FOUR DEALS TO LICENSE THIS,
AND THERE'S A COST TO
SET THAT UP, AND IT'S $50,000."
THAT WOULD'VE BEEN INTERESTING
TO ME.
THAT WOULD'VE BEEN SOMETHING
I WOULD'VE WRITTEN A CHECK FOR.
I HAVE NO INTEREST
IN COMPETING IN RETAIL‐‐
A CATEGORY THAT'S SO CROWDED,
GROWN MEN WEEP.
LICENSING'S NOT OFF‐‐
YOU KNOW, NOT OFF THE TABLE.
WE ALREADY DID LICENSING.
LOOK, YOU CAN ONLY HAVE ONE
VISION. YOU CAN'T HAVE 15,
AND LET ME PART OF THE ONES
THAT DON'T WORK.
I ONLY WANNA BE PART
OF THE ONES WHERE I GET RICH.
THAT'S ALL I CARE ABOUT.
HillBilly‐‐I GOT IT.
I THINK IT WORKS.
I MEAN, WE'RE JUST STARTING
ON THE RETAIL SIDE.
BUT I DON'T WANNA BE IN RETAIL.
THAT IS THE MOST BRUTAL BUSINESS
ON EARTH.
YOU'RE ABOUT TO FIND THAT OUT.
I'M OUT.
♪♪♪
ONE SHARK IS OUT.
SHON AND MIKE HAVE FOUR CHANCES
LEFT TO MAKE A DEAL.
I'M WITH THEM.
YOU GOT GOOD‐LOOKING STUFF.
YOU LICENSE IT, AND LET SOMEBODY
ELSE GO OUT THERE AND FIND IT.
(Shon) WE'RE ALL FOR THAT.
WE'RE NOT AGAINST LICENSING.
WHEN WE GO TO THESE EVENTS,
AND THERE'S TEN OTHER
T‐SHIRT VENDORS
AND THEN THERE'S THE SINGER'S
TENT, WE OUTSELL ALL OF THEM.
AND THEY COME TO US SAYING,
"WHAT ARE YOU GUYS DOING?
HOW‐‐HOW ARE YOU DOING THIS?"
WELL, LET ME JUST SAY TO YOU,
I WISH I HAD THE LICENSING
CONTACTS TO HELP YOU OUT.
I THINK THAT IS
THE WAY TO GO, FOR SURE,
WITH SOMEONE YOU CAN TRUST.
SO I'M OUT
'CAUSE I JUST DON'T HAVE
THOSE CONTACTS.
SHON, I THINK
THE ULTIMATE REDNECK‐
IS THAT DISRESPECTFUL, JEFF?
NO, I‐‐THAT'S A COMPLIMENT.
OKAY, THE ULTIMATE
REDNECK/HILLBILLY
IS SITTING RIGHT THERE
AT THE END.
JEFF, WOULD YOU LICENSE THIS?
IF YOU CAN GET JEFF TO COME IN
ON THE DEAL, I'LL MAKE AN OFFER.
BUT I WANT 100% OF THE NAME.
I JUST WANT TO BUY THE NAME
AND PAY YOU BACK A ROYALTY FEE
ON IT.
JEFF, DO YOU WANNA COME IN
ON IT?
WHAT KIND OF ROYALTY
ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT?
I MEAN, I THINK WE WOULD
PAY THEM BACK A 7% FEE
ON ANY FUTURE DEALS.
I JUST WANNA LICENSE IT
FOR OTHER PEOPLE,
HAVE THE CHECK SHOW UP,
AND YOU GET A FEE OUT OF THAT.
BUT WE‐‐WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANNA
GIVE UP OUR WHOLE DREAM.
I MEAN, WE CREATED THIS.
SO...
I MEAN, WE WOULD LOVE TO PARTNER
WITH YOU OR ANY OF THE SHARKS
AS‐‐AS LONG AS WE'RE INVOLVED.
WE KNOW HOW TO SELL IT.
IT'S NOT A DREAM
TILL IT MAKES MONEY.
IT'S JUST A NIGHTMARE
TILL THEN.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE GONNA
GIVE UP 100% OF OUR COMPANY,
YOU KNOW, WHEN WE KNOW
HOW TO SELL THIS.
I MEAN, EVEN THOUGH YOU LICENSE
IT, SOMEONE'S STILL GOTTA GO OUT
AND SELL IT, YOU KNOW.
JEFF, ARE YOU IN ON IT?
'CAUSE THAT'S
PRETTY IMPORTANT TO ME.
YEAH. I‐I'LL GO IN ON THAT
WITH YOU, ROBERT.
SO YOU'VE GOT THE KING
OF HILLBILLY AND REDNECK
WILLING TO USE HIS NAME
AND LICENSE IT.
DAYMOND, YOU WANT IN?
I THINK THAT IF THE GUYS
GO OUT AND LICENSE IT...
AHEM, WITH MY EXPERTISE...
(laughs)
UH, YOU KNOW‐‐
JEFF, I THINK DAYMOND BRINGS
SOME VALUE.
I THINK DAYMOND BRINGS
A LOT OF VALUE.
ALL RIGHT, SO LET ME‐‐
LET ME REPHRASE THE DEAL.
IF YOU DON'T MIND, JEFF.
GUYS, YOU'RE GONNA GET $50,000
SPLIT BETWEEN JEFF, DAYMOND,
AND I,
FOR THE RIGHTS TO THE NAME
IN EXCHANGE FOR A ROYALTY.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
I THINK WHAT WE'D LIKE
IS IF WE COULD GO UP
TO MAYBE $100,000,
10% INSTEAD OF 7%
ON THE ROYALTIES,
AND THEN SOME TYPE
OF GUARANTEE
THAT IF YOU GUYS JUST SAT IT
ON THE SHELF,
WE'D HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TAKE IT BACK AT SOME POINT.
YOU'RE NOT HILLBILLIES.
I'M GONNA DEFER THE ANSWER
TO THAT QUESTION BACK TO JEFF.
IS IT WORTH THE $100,000?
MAN, I GOTTA TELL YOU.
EMOTIONALLY, I'M‐‐I'M TORN.
BECAUSE I WAS YOU 25 YEARS AGO,
GETTIN' UP
AT 5:00 IN THE MORNING
AND DOING 15 RADIO SHOWS
DOING REDNECK JOKES,
TRYING TO DEVELOP THAT BRAND.
(Daymond) TOUGH ONE.
I WAS‐‐I WAS THEM AS WELL.
YEAH.
THEN HAVE A HEART, GUYS,
AND OPEN YOUR BIG, FAT WALLETS
RIGHT HERE. LET'S GO.
BARBARA, ENOUGH WITH THE...
I WILL COUNTER WITH $75,000,
7% ROYALTY.
$25,000 EACH.
YOU OKAY WITH THAT?
YEAH.
GUYS, $75,000.
WE GET THE NAME.
YOU GET A 7% ROYALTY.
THE 10% IS...
OUT OF THE QUESTION?
I THINK 7% IS GENEROUS.
I THINK YOU GUYS KNOW THAT.
7% IS‐‐IS INDUSTRY STANDARD.
(Robert and Daymond)
WE NEED AN ANSWER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
LET'S DEAL?
ALL RIGHT. LET'S GO. DEAL.
(Robert) ALL RIGHT!
(Jeff) YEEHAW!
YEEHAW!
WHOO!
(Shon) YOU LIKE THAT, HUH, JEFF?
(Daymond) I'M ALREADY WORRIED
ABOUT YOU GUYS.
(Robert) COME ON, JEFF.
PUT YOUR HAT ON, GUYS. YEAH!
(Mike) I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THAT. LOOKS GOOD, MAN.
(Daymond) ALL RIGHT, MAN.
CONGRATULATIONS.
HEY, JEFF, THANKS.
(Jeff) THANKS, MAN.
IT COULD WORK.
(sighs)
DO OR DIE, MAN. WHEW!
IT MEANS A LOT TO HAVE A DEAL
WITH FOXWORTHY.
I MEAN, THAT GUY IS COUNTRY,
YOU KNOW.
HE LIVES AND BREATHES COUNTRY.
SO FOR US TO HAVE A LICENSING
DEAL WITH HIM BACKING IT
IS AMAZING,
AND I THINK THIS IS
PROBABLY THE BEST THING
THAT COULD'VE HAPPENED TO US.
♪♪♪
NEXT INTO THE SHARK TANK
ARE JOHNNY GENNARO
AND VINNY PASTORE
WITH A PRODUCT INSPIRED
BY THE MAFIA'S WISE GUYS.
♪♪♪
HI, MY NAME IS JOHN GENNARO.
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU
TO MY ASSOCIATE,
MR. VINNY PASTORE,
THE CELEBRITY STAR
OF HBO's SERIES, "SOPRANOS."
I CREATED A PRODUCT
CALLED THE BROCCOLI WAD.
(laughs)
I'M HERE TODAY LOOKING
FOR AN INVESTMENT OF $50,000,
AND FOR THAT, I'M WILLING
TO GIVE 20% OF THE COMPANY AWAY.
AS THEY SAY, IT'S AN OFFER,
HOPEFULLY, YOU CAN'T REFUSE.
JOHNNY, LET ME JUST START
BY SAYING,
IF HE'S PACKING HEAT...
(laughs)
I DON'T CARE HOW MUCH MONEY
IS INVOLVED, I'M IN.
NOW MOST GUYS CARRY
THEIR MONEY IN A WALLET.
BUT WISE GUYS CARRY THEIR MONEY
IN A WAD LIKE THIS.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
THIS IS THE BROCCOLI WAD.
(Johnny) THE BROCCOLI WAD
CONCEPT CAME FROM AN IDEA
OF A BOOK I READ
SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
AND IT WAS TALKING ABOUT
AN FBI AGENT
WHO INFILTRATED
THE MOB IN NEW YORK.
AND ONE OF
THE KEY CHARACTERISTICS
WAS THAT WISE GUYS
NEVER CARRY WALLETS.
THEY CARRY THEIR CASH
IN BROCCOLI BANDS,
NOT EVEN RUBBER BANDS.
THE BROCCOLI BAND
IS A PERFECT FIT
TO WRAP AROUND CASH
AND AROUND A‐‐
WHERE DO WISE GUYS
KEEP THEIR CREDIT CARDS?
WISE GUYS
DON'T CARRY CREDIT CARDS.
JUST CASH?
YEAH, JUST CASH.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE I. D.'d
IF THEY STOP YOU.
OF COURSE.
THEY DO CARRY A LICENSE,
BUT NORMALLY,
IT'S FROM OUT OF STATE
AND IT'S EXPIRED.
(laughs)
HAVE YOU GOT SOME THERE
THAT WE CAN SEE AS YOU‐‐
ACTUALLY, I HAVE ONE
FOR EVERYBODY.
NOW I MET JOHNNY,
AND HE SAYS,
I CREATED THIS PRODUCT,
THE BROCCOLI WAD.
SO I THOUGHT HE WAS A LITTLE,
YOU KNOW, OFF HIS ROCKER.
BUT WHAT I WAS IMPRESSED ABOUT
WITH THIS BROCCOLI WAD
WAS, I MEAN,
LOOK HOW CUTE IT IS. (laughs)
(laughs)
VINNY, DON'T‐‐DON'T BREAK
MY LEGS FOR ASKING THIS...
OKAY.
BUT‐‐BUT COME ON,
IT‐‐IT'S A PIECE OF RUBBER.
RIGHT.
THAT YOU'RE SAYING IS WORTH
$250,000 AS A COMPANY?
WELL, UM,
HOW MUCH YOU GIVING ME
EVERY TIME WE SELL ONE?
YOU GET 50 CENTS A UNIT.
SO IF I GET 50 CENTS
A UNIT...
(sharks laugh)
AND IF HE SELLS ENOUGH OF 'EM,
I'LL GET MY HOUSE IN MALIBU.
YOU KNOW, I THINK
YOU'RE BOTH TOTALLY NUTS.
I DON'T GET IT.
I AM SO OUT ON THIS.
WORSE THING
I'VE HEARD ON THIS SHOW.
BARBARA, I WOULDN'T
TALK TO HIM LIKE THAT.
IT'S ALL RIGHT. THAT'S
ALL RIGHT. SHE'S A SWEETHEART.
BARBARA, I THINK
IN FAIRNESS TO THE PRODUCT,
IT'S A DIFFICULT FEMALE ITEM.
GUYS GET IT 'CAUSE GUYS
HAVE ALWAYS USED RUBBER BANDS.
AND I WILL SAY THIS, AS A GUY, I
MEAN, I'VE GOTTEN TO THE POINT,
I‐‐MY WALLET GOT WHERE IT WAS
THE SIZE OF A PHONE BOOK,
SO I'M ALWAYS LOOKING FOR
SOMETHING TO PUT MY CASH IN.
RIGHT.
AND MOST OF THE CLIPS
DON'T WORK RIGHT.
I MEAN, I'M‐‐
I LIKE THIS IDEA.
JUST EXPLAIN
HOW WE'RE GONNA SELL THESE.
FIRST OF ALL,
THE PRODUCT COMES
WITH FOUR BANDS
AND FOUR METAL SLIDES.
THIS IS GONNA BE
A $10 TO $14 ITEM.
I'VE ALREADY CREATED TWO
2‐MINUTE SPOTS, UH, ALREADY
WITH VINNY IN IT.
HE SHOT IT WITH SOME OF
MY "SOPRANO" CAST MEMBERS,
AND WE'RE, UH, ABOUT TO DO
THIS WHOLE CAMPAIGN.
WE ALREADY TALKED, UH,
TO THE CASINOS IN ATLANTIC CITY
AND VEGAS, WHERE I WILL BE
DOING PERSONAL APPEARANCES,
AND THE CASINO WILL BE GIVING
THEM OUT TO CASINO PLAYERS.
HOW MUCH DO YOU HAVE INVESTED
IN THIS COMPANY?
I ALREADY HAVE
ABOUT $200,000 INTO IT.
HOW'S THAT POSSIBLE?
(Robert) WOW.
'CAUSE HE PAID ME $190,000.
(sharks laugh)
I WANT TO BE VINNY. YOU FIGURED
THIS WHOLE THING OUT.
NAH, NAH.
HE TOOK CARE OF ME.
HOW DOES HE TAKE CARE OF YOU?
HE TAKES CARE OF ME.
(sharks laugh)
I COME FROM A BACKGROUND
OF NOVELTY ITEMS.
I SEE THIS AS
AS SEEN ON TV, 2‐MINUTE SPOT,
$9.99 PLUS SHIPPING‐‐
SO‐‐SO, JOHN,
DO YOU NEED THE 50K
TO BUY THE AIRTIME
TO FINALLY PUT THIS COMMERCIAL
OUT THERE
WHERE PEOPLE CAN SEE IT?
I NEED THE $50,000,
SOME OF THAT, YES,
TO HELP IN THE TV ITSELF,
BUT THE REALITY IS,
I'M LOOKING FOR
THE SALES
AND MARKETING EXPERTISE.
WHY DON'T I SEE
VINNY'S PICTURE ANYWHERE?
WHY ISN'T IT CALLED
THE VINNY WAD?
LIKE WHY ISN'T HE‐‐
IF YOU CALLED IT
THE VINNY WAD‐‐
WHY ISN'T HIS PICTURE ON HERE?
THE VINNY WAD'S
PROBABLY BETTER, SURE.
DO YOU SEE VINNY AS‐‐
AS KIND OF THE FACE OF THIS?
(John) WITHOUT VINNY, THIS IS‐‐
THIS IS A RUBBER BAND.
YEAH, I'M BACK IN
FOR THE VINNY WAD.
YOU WANT TO DO
THE VINNY WAD?
YEAH.
THAT'S DIFFERENT.
YOUR GREATEST ASSET
IS STANDING NEXT TO YOU.
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
BUT YOU HAVEN'T
BRANDED HIM ANYWHERE.
IS HE WITH THIS LONG‐TERM?
COULD BE.
UH, I THINK,
THEN TRUTHFULLY,
TO SPEAK HONESTLY
IN FRONT OF JOHNNY WAD,
THAT IT'S A MATTER
OF ECONOMICS.
HE'S NOT PAYING YOU ENOUGH.
HE'S NOT
PAYING YOU ENOUGH.
I THINK THAT SOUNDS
VERY EXPENSIVE. I'M OUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THIS JUST ISN'T FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
YEAH, I‐I DON'T HAVE
AN OFFER. I'M OUT.
I'M GONNA MAKE A DEAL
FOR YOU.
VINNY, LISTEN TO THIS‐‐
WE'RE GONNA MAKE AN OFFER,
VINNY AND I...
(Robert)
VINNY'S NOT A SHARK.
WAIT, WELL‐‐
WHAT, ARE YOU GUYS DATING NOW?
WHAT'S GOING ON?
THIS IS WHAT I'M GONNA SAY‐‐
40% FOR THE $50,000.
YOU PUT UP THE FACE
AND THE VINNY WAD NAME,
AND VINNY GETS HALF OF MY 40%.
WELL, I'M OUT.
THAT'S A GREAT OFFER.
THAT'S A DEAL, BARBARA.
THANK YOU.
BABY, HONEY.
I LOVE YOU.
GIVE ME A SQUEEZE.
OH. (speaks Italian)
WHAT JUST HAPPENED THERE?
(Daymond) WHAT JUST HAPPENED?
WHERE DO I GO?
BARBARA BOUGHT ME OUT.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
(sharks laugh)
I DON'T NEED JOHNNY WAD.
JOHN, YOU JUST GOT WHACKED.
YOU DIDN'T GET WHACKED.
YOU'RE STILL INTO IT FOR 60%.
I GOT WHAT, 60%?
LET ME JUST SAY IT AGAIN.
I'M GIVING YOU THE $50,000.
OKAY, YEAH.
FOR THAT, I GET 40%.
OKAY.
I'M GONNA GIVE 20%,
OR HALF OF MY 40%, TO VINNY.
OKAY.
AND VINNY'S GONNA DONATE
HIS FACE
AND HIS BRAND TO YOUR PRODUCT.
SO BASICALLY, SHE FUNDED
GETTING HIM INTO THE DEAL
WITH HIS FACE, AND HE AGREED.
HE NOW HAS 20% OF THE COMPANY.
SHE HAS 20% OF THE COMPANY.
YOU'VE GOT $50,000.
AND YOU STILL
RUN THE BUSINESS.
HOW MUCH PRODUCT DO YOU HAVE
IN YOUR WAREHOUSE?
50,000 PIECES.
CAN I SEE THE PACKAGE?
JUST PUT VINNY'S PICTURE
ON IT.
YOU NEED A STICKER
WITH VINNY ON IT.
THAT'S IT.
THAT'S ALL YOU NEED,
RIGHT UP HERE.
BUT HOW ARE WE
GONNA MOVE FORWARD?
I CAME HERE
NOT JUST FOR MONEY,
BUT FOR SALES
AND MARKETING EXPERTISE.
DO I GET YOUR EXPERTISE?
THE ONLY THING I KNOW
REALLY, REALLY WELL
IS SALES AND MARKETING.
THE MINUTE I THOUGHT OF
THE VINNY CLIP,
I KNEW THIS WAS A HOME RUN.
(Robert)
THIS IS ONE TOUGH BROAD.
(Vinny) I LIKE HER.
BARBARA'S MY STYLE.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU'RE MY STYLE, TOO.
BARBARA, WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO DO, WE'RE GONNA ROLL.
WHOA. YOU GUYS GO AHEAD
AND TAKE IT.
NO, WE'RE GONNA MAKE MONEY.
STOP, JOHNNY. RELAX.
(Barbara)
WAIT A MINUTE. (laughs)
(sharks laugh)
DO YOU ACCEPT THE DEAL?
I'LL ACCEPT IT.
(Barbara and Robert) ALL RIGHT.
THIS IS‐‐THIS IS
HISTORY IN THE MAKING.
I GOT TWO MEN FOR THE PRICE
OF ONE. THANK YOU.
AND I WANT TO HUG
MY PARTNER. THANKS, GUYS.
YOU MADE A GREAT DEAL.
WAS IT A BLUFF, OR YOU SAID,
"THIS IS THE WORST IDEA
I'VE EVER HEARD
ON 'SHARK TANK,'"
AND NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN,
YOU'RE HUGGING AND KISSING?
NO, I MEANT IT WAS
THE WORST IDEA.
IT STILL IS,
BUT ONCE YOU MARKET IT,
IT'S GENIUS.
I'M REALLY GLAD I MADE
THE DEAL WITH BARBARA. SH‐‐
YOU DIDN'T MAKE THE DEAL
WITH BARBARA.
I MADE THE DEAL WITH BARBARA.
MY PRODUCT, AGAIN, VINNY.
MY‐‐
OKAY, WELL, WE
BOTH MADE THE DEAL.
WE BOTH MADE THE DEAL.
OKAY, GREAT. I'M HAPPY.
I THINK SHE'S GOOD.
SHE'S WONDERFUL.
I THINK SHE'LL BE GREAT
FOR SALES AND MARKETING,
WHICH IS WHAT WE NEED.
RIGHT, VINNY'S‐‐
VINNY'S WAD.
VINNY'S WAD. VINNY'S CLIP.
VINNY'S WHATEVER.
VINNY'S WAD.
THAT'S FINE.
VINNY'S WAD IT IS.
AS LONG AS I SELL
FOUR MILLION.
(laughs) OKAY.